joining me is the Royal editor of the
London evening standard very nice to
have you this evening also the author of
our King Robert Johnson and journalist
and author of the case for cancel
culture Ernest Owens look thank you both
very much for joining us on this
discussion Let's uh we laid out the the
claims there about uh Harry and about
his U.S citizenship um it just is a
story that won't go away uh is Harry
should he be treated differently from
any other citizen absolutely not I mean
I I recently applied for an i visa to go
and work do some work in America they're
covering the Royal tour uh they're very
specific on the form and you had to fill
it out and if you didn't fill out
correctly I dare say it would have been
thrown back in my face it should be
treated he wants to be a not a citizen
of America who's made that clear
um he's married to an American citizen
and if you don't fill the forms
accurately you uh you should be in hot
water I think that's fair you think it's
fair but do you think it's and we keep
mention this at the moment a politicized
issue I'm going to come across to
Earnest on this Earnest because uh yeah
we've seen a lot of politicizers people
claimed issues in the last 24 hours
Stateside but on this what do you make
of the claim that Harry has been used as
something of a political Pawn here I'm
just going to give the context to our
viewers because this uh request for his
documents to be released by The Heritage
foundations are called the conservative
think tank Harry of course has quite
close Democrat connection so is he being
used as a porn
absolutely I think that there's a lot of
unnecessary presumption being driven by
conservatives over there in the UK and I
think that honestly they're being
disrespectful to our customs you know
who's to say that he did not go through
the process correctly why is there so
many assumptions based on things that
are written in his book I just think
that is really a bunch of people
politicizing a bunch to do about nothing
you know Prince Harry does not pose a
threat to the United States
um I don't think anyone would assume
that he shouldn't be able to answer
based on what what what is he doing he's
not a terrorist he doesn't pose any
criminal record that would suggest that
he would be an endangerment in America
so I just think the entire conversation
is just really a bunch of rubbish to be
honest well I don't want to oversimplify
Earnest but I do get the impression that
quite a lot of Americans do and do the
British
the British to have Prince Harry even if
he's not quite in the royal family
anymore over there in the states
you know absolutely I think that he has
really embraced American culture
um he is very modern he's Progressive
and he really represents the kind of
spirit that a lot of um particularly
Millennials in Jin's ears
um look for in the public figure such as
him so I think he fits in quite well and
he has been in quite well I mean you
have big Hollywood Moguls like Tyler
Perry let him stay at his Mansion you
know it's he's he's he's one of us in a
certain sense
uh Robert you want to respond
but you know I think that what's
important here is transparency and it's
not a right-wing organizations trying to
talk about these things he's openly said
he's taking class A drugs and a number
of all these drugs
um he may well have said that I've done
it in the past with his form but I'm not
doing it now and if that's the case
that's fine look we've got the president
of the United States who's is in court
at the moment for for uh not so much
what he's uh not so much all the sort of
awful things that have been going on in
his life but for actually forced to find
documents and and that he's having an
answer to it so if there's nothing to
hide just share the document would say
thanks a lot I gotta say it's quite a
sort of compelling argument when you
line it up against Trump but then U.S
officials apparently they can decide to
wave
um any kind of discrepancy on the phone
I respect the US officials I mean U.S
officials are saying there is not a case
to answer here then you've got to
respect them the same as if an American
who'd a famous American who was applying
for citizenship in the United Kingdom
admitted to taking drugs and then got to
accept it then we'd have to respect the
British government too look I just want
to ask you about some comments that we
had today from Sarah Ferguson
um quite an interesting character of
course in the great Royal scheme of
things but when we talk about keeping
one foot in and one foot out of the
royal family she said in an interview
you can't really do that and she
obviously has made her position very
clear and she's sort of carved it out
quite cleverly I think in terms of
trying to be a normal person she's
obviously kept her title she's still got
a voice it seems to be the type of thing
you would think Megan and Harry would
want to go for but they haven't plowed
that path well I mean I know Sarah the
reality is a very sensible person the
reality is too is that she never got
remarried and that's why she kept the
title doesn't feel no other reason if
she'd brutally married him with Sarah
whoever
um that's for one foot in one foot out
um I think that's true I don't think you
can be half in the queen made that quite
clear but actually it's quite
interesting what's happened with Sarah
she was invited to Christmas with the
Royals with their new daughters
by the king and queen and Sandra went
along with Andrew was there too because
it was a private family gathering
my feeling of all these things is is
that some you can't have it both ways so
what I do find odd about Aaron Megan
although I I wish them well and I really
think that it's great what he wants for
life he has I've known him since you're
a little boy I covered the story for 33
years what I would say is in the spirit
of America there's no need to have the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex title you
just be Mr Mrs Mountain baton Windsor
and there's no need to call your kids
prince and princess because you know if
you're an American that's going against
1776 isn't it that's a really
interesting point Ernest and we did ask
your opinion on having the Royals over
there but as Robert laid out is it
within the spirit of America shouldn't
they be behaving like ordinary citizens
what's your thought
I mean they're not ordinary citizens
um so that's just intellectually
dishonest to try to hold them to a
standard that neither this is neither
the society to which they're living in
nor the public nor any of you all on
this set would actually do that that's
just intellectually dishonest and it's
actually quite frankly impossible so
we're not going to act as though all of
a sudden they can just shed a title and
so with the publicity or all of it will
die it will not die they are high
profile individuals
um at the end of the day the United
States government thought that the Visa
was fine I think all of this
interrogation is a waste of time I think
that they're quite fine where they are
and I think you know it's so many more
important things going on in the world
than badgering about a Visa like come on
he's fine he's okay I don't think anyone
in this country thinks he's an
endangerment and it happens in other
countries as well and I just think that
to continue to belabor this argument he
said drugs 12 times okay when it doesn't
have anything to do with now they're
just battering them get over it one you
could ask us to get over it but it's not
going forward well there is the the
point as Robert's making of the legal
documents here um I I sort of see Ernest
Point as well of the belaboring to death
as well now Meghan Markle under
increased scrutiny uh because she's
going to receive an award
um at this event in New York next month
um given to her by a prominent feminist
who is also a good friend of hers as it
transpires and her critics asking is she
deserving of that award now when I look
at sort of the work that she's done and
she's carried out she has spoken out
about women
um she has done that type of thing but
her critics saying look she doesn't
really do that much well I mean on this
one I actually I feel that she does
deserve it um prior to marrying Prince
Harry she was quite she was out there on
this area she's been a ever since her
little girl she's been speaking out on
about feminism writing letters about
adverts that go wrong so yeah I don't
know what I would say is as a person
that runs a charity charity you know it
myself you've also got to sell the
tickets and you know Meghan Markle is a
famous person they're also going to get
a royal throne in because Harriet turn
up and these fifteen thousand dollar
ticket tables will sell because she's
there and that's a good thing because if
it empowers women and it empowers their
voice that has to be a good thing uh
that was my thought Robert exactly when
I saw it fifteen hundred dollars a
ticket 50 uh yeah 15 000 for the table
and of course putting Meghan Markle on
the ticket doesn't mean that they need
to get to sell it um however when it
comes to uh Meghan Markle and how she is
discussed in the United States Ernest
I'll come to you on this because Robert
brought up the point of uh kindness
early he's he's known the couple for a
very long time
um Piers Morgan's not in the seat
tonight he's been kind enough to give me
the seat for a few days whilst he's on
holiday I might take a slightly
different view of things I'm also a
woman of around Megan's age not too far
off
um but when it comes to the way that she
is criticized that she is looked at for
this award that she's going to be
receiving next month do you think she's
deserving this award do you think
somebody else should more should be
getting it
look I think she deserves the award to
be honest you know Awards within
themselves from organizations are always
you know strategic and political in
their own right you know there is a
level of Merit but at the end of the day
you know I I think anyone who is humble
that understands the system understands
that in certain cases does the means
justify it the reason why they're having
the awards is support a cause it's a
charity effort and so the reason why
people are going there is really to
support the mission and so I think in
deciding this as someone who's an organ
I'm a president of a journalism
organization in Philadelphia and you
know when we pick honorees we pick
people that you know we do believe
deserve recognition but we also think
about the impact and so what you can't
deny is that Meghan Markle has impact
and she's going to have the psych the
impact that's going to fill those seats
and raise a lot of money for a cause
that everyone should be behind so I
think
it's not about her I mean I I personally
will support anyone who wants to buy a
table and I think that if she is
you buy the table I'll buy one ticket
I'm not gonna get a 50 000 table but I
might get a ticket with you
a piece how about that
gentlemen I think we've had a slightly
different nature of debate uh this
evening than normal I hope business
viewers aren't disappointed that we've
kind of found some reconciliation on
buying a table to Meghan markle's
charity event next month
okay you didn't say you win we're
journalists we like to go free oh yeah
it's been fantastic we'll cover it it's
been a fantastic have you both have so
much for your Insight